THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS.
>> WHITECLOUD BUSTING IN, HIS C
PACIORETTY,  AND HE SCORES!
PACIORETTY FINDS A LITTLE ROOM
UNDER THE PAD OF  AND HE SCORES
GREAT PASS ACROSS.
RIGHT OVER THE STICK OF
HERE IS CHANDLER STEPHENSON ,
THEY WILL SEPARATE  DROP THE PU
ON THE SECOND PERIOD.
THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS
18th OF THE SE IN THE RUSH.
INTO THE OFFENSIVE END.
DINEEN JUST THROWS IT, TO THE
SIDE AND A NE IN THE SECOND.
LINE.
ZIPS IT ACROSS FOR CANUCKS.
HERE I I
THEY ARE RIGHT UP McNABB
SCORES!
McNABB ON THE WRIST SHOT. EN, T
IT CHANGED DIRECTIONS
RIGHT TO PACIORETTY WHO GETS A
ONE-HANDED SHOT AWAY.
HE FIGHTS OFF MAYO.
KIND OF A FOUR.
LOOK AS KOLESAR GOES TO THE
FRONT OF THE PUCK.
EICHEL HAS THE STEP, IN THE
CLEAR AND SCORES!ALL ALONE.
JACK EICHEL